we'll be to disarm bombs set in a French
consulate will be following team captain
Chris Henry over here throughout this
demo keep in mind that this is a live
demo and anything can happen
we hope you enjoy Chris are you ready
yes just like your team are you ready
yeah yeah you're laughs do it have fun
hope you enjoy all right guys let's
let's do this
yep through it all I watched you start
head to the right-hand side with your
team
yeah let's stay back for a second
skeleton left-hand side here yeah okay
let me see
no there's nothing on the left I got the
front door barricaded and looks like the
balcony up top - and as a barricaded -
okay I said we stick close to running
here let's move up yeah let's go sighs I
see an opening on the top floor through
that window in the corner there okay
yeah let's step top guys strike them at
the east side wall let me know if you
see anybody else at the window right
yeah okay brutal let's hit the roof real
quick - right let's get it out okay so
we have two guys inside we could
probably take him out quietly okay come
up to the rooftop Bernal I guess they're
on my side good yeah okay I'm gonna get
the hands here
does anybody have a silencer on the
other side I have a silencer and I have
visual okay won't take them down and go
anytime three two one go got it hey good
job guys nice work side all right now
take a look at the back of the picture
it's clear it's clear okay soon let's
set up here for a second guys yep want
to see my drone out Scout before move
off
you look pretty good by the first
barricade I don't see too much there's
another big kid on the right here and I
got a lot of nitrous on set up just
behind it
I also saw a Saab bomber here's the
middle always you could run out start
taking care of the drone the traps down
at my shine through okay careful yeah
bombers right there hold on hold on
that's when he starts going back right
yeah you're good man he's coming back
now safe yeah you're good go for it
on the double movin up keep an eye on
the ball man all right it's coming back
on I have one shoe here at the end of
the hallway I got a guy behind the desk
the concert office that's got one guy
also by the shield okay you guys ready
move up yeah yes we are
go dad Lika myself we're gonna head down
the main hallway
Bruno Meg come over here tear down the
wall start coming down the left-hand
side going in I'll give you some cover
you got a shield right in front of you I
slowed down bit come in clear the room
yep we good yep clear
okay Andy token do pitches during one of
us now anything for you Thanks
you guys ready yeah go for it go boys
you know why only forward okay to this
the other very key the bomber is behind
the second one there God
yep I'll let you push up first all right
yeah okay
stay back a little bit I'm a conference
call me he's right there he's right
there
right there
can you tell we're okay Leto pick me up
yes worse okay thank you heard enough
yeah I'm pretty hurt the whole week we
do open so take cover behind my shield
here okay we're going to star blew out
the main hall you guys start moving up
in the left-hand side take your time
couple of guys I'm reloading I'm down I
got I got a burger toe pick it up you
push forward this one guy in the console
open window soon after loading not one I
got okay scuffle it up drag comfortable
wall alright going hard do one more okay
I'm right behind you go for it go for it
wish up push up real king take a look on
the right knee go yeah got my back yeah
I'm watching right breaching the rooms
clear clear lavond equals clear the
ranch life
if we're good the both down yeah yeah
okay the other negative let's set up
here they point in the front door check
the hallway there
Maggie's if you're left there does a
wall yep can you make a couple goes from
either keep it back stairs yeah I'm
gonna drop the diffuser right behind you
yeah I got it covered
we got to hold it for a minute and we
got this let's do this this is your go
down will protect it back behind you
just okay I'm gonna I'm gonna be it
nobody here waiting room right now don't
set up with the windows guys otherwise I
got glad I'm right behind you yeah let's
take a little surgery run in the hallway
I got one coming back stairs yeah
welcome to the other fellow in the
hallway
charge try not to get drug - I'm coming
up coming
the way I got it
Estonia The Bachelor goes back windows
Marianna windows covered this okay okay
okay I got you because always keep it up
we develop
back there did I got gold invective
appointment back here come over to
diffuser
down I'm down
what guy doesn't
the ball I have a jogger now